I'm grateful because this has been such, and is such a positive experience for my wife and I.
We kind of came because of some health issues and then we discovered more, we didn't know.
Particularly for me that I'm losing intolerant, and I felt so much better becoming gluten-free.
My acid refilth-wise things are on a better track, and I've had some prostate issues.
And so there's positive things that's come from my wife and I.
There's also been some side benefits that I didn't expect.
Back in about 2014, Laura told me to study healing in all its forms.
And of course there's the natural things that have to happen before the spiritual, because first the natural.
And so since my wife and I have been going through this here, we've also been coming under awareness
of teaching about the courts of heaven that relates to healing, that has shown us a side of Jesus that we've never known.
So we're really going to gain a lot, and the Lord is really...